In 1929, the name of Walter Duranty, The New York Times journalist,
was on everyone’s lips:
he was the first Western journalist
to interview Joseph Stalin!
In 1930, a Cambridge graduate
and adviser to David Lloyd George,
the former Prime Minister of the United Kingdom,
arrived in Stalino
(the former name of Donetsk city up until 1961).
He had heard his mother’s stories about this place,
knew Russian well,
and dreamt of visiting the USSR someday.
His name was Gareth Jones, and he was unknown
to the general public at the time.
In 1931, the famous reporter Duranty
posted 13 articles about the USSR.
Although his views surprisingly lined up
with the official Kremlin position
and were highly admired by Stalin himself,
this did not prevent him from receiving
the Pulitzer Prize and recognition.
On 15 February 1932, a Ukrainian newspaper “Svoboda”,
based in Jersey City in the U.S.,
published an article under the title “Moscow wants
to starve Ukrainian villagers to death”.
In 1933, more articles were published about
the famine in the USSR almost weekly.
On 23 February 1933, the USSR issued a resolution
that forbade foreign journalists from leaving cities.
In March of 1933, despite the ban,
Gareth Jones bought a train ticket
as a private individual and went to Ukraine.
He left the train before his final destination
and started a long journey through Ukrainian villages.
The winter of 1932 to the summer of 1933
was the peak of what would be later recognised
as the genocide of the Ukrainian people.
In the attempts to break the resistance
of Ukrainian villagers
against collectivisation and the unrealistic
grain procurement plans,
the Soviet government first took away all grains,
then all food, and then limited the ability
to travel inside the country.
The villages essentially turned into cemeteries
with no way to escape.
Jones, once in love with the far-away industrial land,
saw death, destruction, and total starvation
with his own eyes.
In the same March of 1933,
a journalist Malcolm Muggeridge
published three analytical articles
in The Manchester Guardian
about the famine in Ukraine,
for the first time in the Western press.
After that, the same newspaper published
Gareth Jones’ article “Famine Rules Russia”.
At the same time,
Jones held a large press conference in Berlin,
where he shared about the actual situation in the USSR with the general public.
However, on 31 March 1933, The New York Times published
something entirely different —
devastating criticism from Walter Duranty,
the Pulitzer Prize winner
who had lived in Moscow for years.
He stated that there were indeed
problems with food supply in the USSR
but not as bad as Jones described.
In the same way,
he justified the Soviet leaders and politics,
and called the millions of people
who died at that time
simply a running cost
on the way to progress and prosperity.
This is what Stalin said of him,
It could only mean one thing —
Duranty played the same role in sending millions of deaths
into oblivion as Soviet propaganda.
The Western politicians
who knew the situation in the USSR fairly well,
such as the President of the United States
Franklin D. Roosevelt,
stayed silent.
As a result, Gareth Jones became an exile,
while in 1933 the U.S. officially recognised the USSR.
In 1935, Jones died under unknown circumstances.
The civil losses in Ukraine during World War II
are equal to the losses
during a few peacetime months in 1933.
In 1948, the UN adopted The Convention
on the Prevention and Punishment of the Crime of Genocide.
It established genocide
as acts committed with intent to destroy,
in whole or in part, a national, ethnic,
racial or religious group.
The first mentions of the Holodomor
began appearing in Western discourse
no sooner than the 1980s.
In 1983, Bohdan Krawchenko, M. Maksudov,
James Mace, and Roman Serbyn
spoke at the Scientific Conference
at the University of Quebec.
At the same time, when journalists asked
the Ukrainian diplomats in the UN about the Holodomor,
they just stayed silent.
In 1984, Ihor Olshaniwsky, the head of an organisation called
“Americans for Human Rights in Ukraine”,
with the support from U.S. senators Bradley and Florio,
initiated a committee in the U.S. Congress
that had to study the Ukrainian famine of 1932–1933.
Daniel Andrew Mica, a member of the U.S. Congress,
was the head of this committee.
The working group for gathering facts was led by James Mace,
who worked at the Ukrainian Research Institute at Harvard University.
In 1986, thanks to the materials gathered by James Mace,
Robert Conquest published a book called “The Harvest of Sorrow:
Soviet Collectivisation and the Terror-Famine”,
which became a bestseller.
Later, Mace wrote, “My fate is such that your dead chose me.”
Mace’s research was based, first and foremost,
on eyewitnesses’ memories.
In April of 1988, the U.S. Congress received
the final report from the committee,
where one of the paragraphs called the Holodomor genocide.
In December of 1987, the First Secretary of the Central Committee
of the Communist Party of Ukraine Volodymyr Shcherbytsky
finally admitted the fact of the famine in 1932–1933.
However, the communists talked about natural reasons
for the famine, particularly draught,
undervalued the extent, and refuted the fact
that it was man-made and planned.
The first country in the world to recognise the Holodomor as genocide was Estonia.
On 20 October 1993, the Parliament of Estonia
made a respective statement,
condemning the Soviet politics of genocide,
and showed solidarity in remembering
the 1932–1933 Holodomor victims.
As of today, 16 countries recognise the Holodomor as genocide,
including Australia, Canada, Vatican City,
Poland, Lithuania, Georgia, Latvia, and others.
In 2003, with the assistance of James Mace,
The Holodomor Victims Remembrance Day was established in Ukraine.
On the last Saturday of November,
there are many candles in many windows,
lit in remembrance of grandparents, parents, brothers, sisters,
and friends who died due to the genocide.
On 28 November 2006, the Supreme Council of Ukraine passed a law
“About the Holodomor of 1932–1933 in Ukraine”,
according to which the Holodomor was recognized
as genocide of the Ukrainian people.
For Ukrainians, it meant that the tragedy of thousands of families
finally came out.
The stories about the terrible events of 1933
that were passed in absolute secret were finally told.
During Viktor Yushchenko’s presidency,
the Holodomor became one of the most prioritized topics
of the politics of national memory.
The memorial for the Holodomor Victims
was also established at this time.
Russia, as the successor to the USSR, admits the fact of the famine,
but completely refuses to recognise the Holodomor
as genocide against the Ukrainian people.
It would, obviously, destroy the notion of “brotherly nations”.
The USSR’s position did not allow acknowledging millions of victims,
in the same way as Russia’s position now
does not allow admitting annexation of Crimea
and the undeniable occupation of parts of Donbas.
Walter Duranty, who was once praising Stalin
and called thousands of deaths the necessary running cost,
still has the Pulitzer Prize,
although his name does not inspire ovation now
but stands next to the Soviet regime’s crimes.
The books and movies about Gareth Jones are bestsellers,
and he himself became a symbol of honest journalism
and truth despite everything.
Is it the time for the Pulitzer Prize committee
to finally set historical justice
and take the honorary award from the propagandist
that delayed the recognition of the genocide by many years?